what's what's been your favorite thing
about Japan so far favorite thing here
yeah like how's your experience been
here this is your first time damn I'm
not sure I mean you only know about it
itn't trash t apparently so yeah pretty
much I was not expecting the weather but
this hot but other than that you really
oversold the convenience like for the
first 4 days I was so disappointed in
conv why I don't know I was expecting
something like magical you they do do
everything what do name one thing they
don't do uh gluten-free food Oh Come on
that's what do you what do you want them
to do country right no no no I'm I'm
coming around to them like now I start
to like them again you just I feel like
you just hyped them up so much they are
so good well how are the convenience
stores in Estonia I don't know it it
feels the same like oh you go to cast
station you get like uh fresh food
that's like hot and you have everything
you need just we don't have this in
either of any of our countries or
Thailand
maybe Circle K what the [__] is a Circle
K never mind I know Circle K but we we
don't have it it's getting better in our
countries I think but uh UK is
definitely getting better yeah UK the
food quality in the UK is definitely
going up oh my God from being from when
I was a kid it's gone up so much it's so
weird now every time I go back to the UK
and I'm like I'm excited to go to
restaurants and eat and before I was
just like my God every Google review is
just lying to me gre gre gre oh gre gre
is kid did you have Gregs in the UK uh
never [__] do you have you have a meal
deal though right I don't know you had a
meal deal from Tesco I yeah you told me
you had one did I I I maybe lied what
the [__] Li I have no idea what you're
talking about you get the sandwich and
you get a bag of crisps and you get a
drink oh then no what maybe you talked
to somebody else no you said you did you
looked me in the eye no I did
not going have the window of
Correction I have no idea what you're
talking
about I don't think I've had him Tesco
me deal all right next time we're in the
UK we have you at least had anando right
yeah he was you were there when he had
Nando God damn it the dimension is
really kicking in we've had Nando I'm
pretty sure we have yeah we had it yeah
yeah not this year yeah we did not this
year I can't remember this year we I
just remember because we went to the
restaurant and you said wow are the
chicken thighs really that calic two of
us like with Emily andus not with oh
yeah I was like are you gaslighting me
we were there no I'm being Gastly I'm
like wait I have I had done okay here's
the problem I've had Nando so many times
in my last trip to UK that I literally
can't remember everyone I've been to
Nando every second meal was a Nando it's
[__] up the spicier the sauce the more
calories it has I feel I feel like
that's [__] up is that true Yeah
whatand the more spicy the sauce the
more calories it hasand I don't know why
maybe cuz they have to compensate to
make more flavor is Chili's that much
calories no but I think they're adding
other stuff to like help cuz obviously
like thickeners yeah I think that normal
hot sauce is just too like one noted so
you have to have a lot of other super
spicy like sauce is kind of consistency
of elma's glue like go love that [__]
pretty insane [__] I miss Nando already
[__] how do you feel Nando compared to
Australian nandos have you been to
Australian nandos yeah once and then it
went out of business cuz it was [__] I
heard the same thing happened in Canada
as well okay so wa what's the your
favorite thing in Japan so far you
didn't answer not the comedies you said
comedies weren't your favorite thing
fine you're dead to me but it's fine no
I said I'm coming around to them I like
them now okay what's what's the one
thing that actually lived up to the hype
in Japan
is there anything uh they're aesthetic
like everything I I would say just
coming to Japan everything is as like
anime or aesthetic as you expect it's
like the vibe right it is the vibe is
correct the vibe is
correct is the vibe
check I I was here I was like yeah I
could see myself living here it's like
really nice yeah like the weather is
nice people nice you think they'd be
like oh no G no no no but everybody's
been like really nice even if they can't
speak they like try and like I haven't
been rejected once
it's really cool well you haven't I
don't think you've been to like the the
old like M and pop shops those are the
those are usually the places where they
just like oh no foreigners but like a
standard restaurant now is like they're
not going to deny you just cuz you're a
foreigner nowadays like Pete took me out
for like a premere to uh for like a
night out with at bars and all the bars
were just so great yeah the bars are
fantastic the bars are the one thing
that do not disappoint in Japan yeah
yeah it was literally like everything
you'd expect yeah totally yeah honestly
like I every time I go to a bar in Japan
it it makes the rest of the world just
feel so much more disappointing in terms
of like the vibe it's always a good it's
just crazy like the quality the cost you
pay like yeah a [__] yeah just like the
amount of choice there is is just goated
bro and and bars just like it's great
little snacks they give you I love
little snacks yeah hell yeah you know
like you know obviously I have to
like as a British I have to say of
course we have like comparing weather
spoons to some of the [__] PS with
boys the [__] PBS let's go but yeah
Japanese bars are absolutely [__]
goed I do like PPS though but they feel
different in my mind like a bar is in
two different like the bars in Japan is
where I go to like I'm like man let's
let's just like deep talk I have the
counter the music the nice cocktails
with the guy the guy spends like 15
hours making it he puts like the ice
cubes that have been like finally
crafted with the Damascus steel blade
and the ice from Hokkaido for some
reason like okay cool he's like it's a
gent
tonic it's also but he spent $15 mate no
it's like no actually no it's like uh
they're like bus like 10 bucks 10 bucks
I think so yeah yeah I think it was yeah
roughly unless it's like a highend bar
but you're talking about European prices
dude European cocktail prices are Next
Level yeah you think America's expensive
European cocktails they're like15 for a
cocktail which is like $20 you treated
me out to like cocktails and were like
oh when it come to St I'll pay you back
but it's like three times as much to pay
you well I told him I was like he was
going to pay and I was like no no don't
I'm paying and then I was like just pay
for me when I come to Estonia and he was
like no no stonia is more expensive I
was like ah well the end's really weak
right now so do you know do you know the
biggest discrepancy I've noticed between
you know the meme which is just like
thing thing in Japan yeah it's
like get recommended like any like Tik
Tok or YouTube short where it's just
like a very very expensive product from
a very specialist guy that's been honing
their craft uh and if it's like a
western person doing it half the
comments are like this [__] expensive
why why why the [__] would I why who
cares if it's handmade or not but Tanaka
Yoshimi spent 60 years crafting this
table and all the comments are just like
oh my God that's dedication such a
master to their craft oh dedication I
thank you Sensei I remember I saw this
like I remember I saw this uh short
about I think it was like a Japanese
Craftsman who had made like the
calligraphy brushes and he like makes it
by hand oh yes I've seen that and I'm
like it was ridiculously expensive and
he goes like basically he puts in the
individual Hair by hair and and I'm just
like I mean I get it but it's spit mud
in it it's Hair by hair I mean I get I I
admire the dedication but would I pay a
grand for it yeah yeah not sure you know
when you're young and you just like
drink anything thing just because it
serves the purpose of getting you drunk
and the most important thing was how
efficiently how cost effective could you
get drunk the vodka Red Bulls the vodka
Red Bulls oh man you should eat the one
chip okay no don't do this I will die no
you would yeah you would actually they'
removed it for health concern yeah we
still have it yeah look we we have it
for some reason like a kid died someone
died from it was [__] I had it and I I
can handle spice but that was [__] no
I had uh two of my editors who are like
help with a stream did uh both of them
puked and the day was ruined oh my day
was ruined after it too it was it was
very painful yeah good um but I guess my
stomach's used to it now I had Toom used
to it now I think so yeah does it want
to be used to it maybe not I don't know
I had a bunch of hot sauces that expired
today this morning so I had to pour them
all out cuz I had to clean the bottles
to recycle the bottles uhh and so I I
was getting rid of all the hot sauce and
it made the air spicy cuz I was emptying
all the bottles and I was breathing and
it was it was making my throat itch oh
[__] everywhere in my house it was
[__] godamn so uh be
careful yeah that's it fun
story I think uh my m i so I went back
home this time and every time I go home
now I've noticed my mom makes like I
there was a point in my childhood where
I was in a at how spicy my mom could eat
like spicy food and then I got to a
point where I started liking spicy food
and I think I progress aggressively
liked more and more spicy food as I go
as I go older um so every time I come
home now I've noticed she always makes
it a little bit more spicy gear spicy
just just a little bit more spicy like
limit test to me and uh same thing with
Sydney and every time she uh every time
she feeds us food now every time we like
just cough a little bit she's like it's
too spicy too spicy it's a little bit
too
spicy hits your throat the wrong way it
could be fine but you just you know what
I mean like come on totally yeah the hot
ones ruin me you you did the hot ones
one time right yeah cuz I used to have
like uh take just normal Tabasco sauce
and that was my limit but then I did hot
ones uh well I cried a couple times but
afterwards I Tobasco is just so simple
yeah yeah Tobasco is just a little like
little o yeah I used to think the same
like when I used to handle like no spice
I was like oh tabasco's too spicy but
then I had like several levels above and
now I [__] love to Bas everything
what level did you get when you got noos
that's that's that's like medium or High
you got
herb no the you got garlic and
herb the sauce I but later on that was
oh oh yeah me later on but you chose
garlic and herb andish I remember cuz I
was disappointed in you but I put the
sauce on later tried it I'm kidding I'm
kidding I'm just [__] with you oh
yeah yeah yeah cuz you can't handle
spicy food I I remember now yeah you
can't handle spicy food at all I
remember we went to Chipotle in America
and you were like you were like how can
you eat this I was like it has jalapenos
in it because of that they also gave you
like a kilogram and the burrito was 1
kilo it's like what I eat in 2 days
that's messed up it's like 1500 calories
you cannot fit it in your mouth you
literally can well yeah you bite edges
you bomb bom bomb this this is the true
test to see if you have it truly become
parasocial listening to too much trash
taste what's your opinion of America
when you went for LA or like you've been
a few times now right the preface I've
only been to
LA Downtown LA to be specific it's the
only place in America you've been right
yes uh two times my now it's bad it's
well obviously downtown LA is bad I
think even everyone in La will be like
downtown is awful yeah a third world
country
yeah my I mean that's yeah that's fair
enough me cut that don't cut that M
leave it
in but uh yeah cuz you've been to like
you normally go for ax every year right
yeah I try
to CU I can't what was the first ax you
went to because that was definitely
before you started working for us yeah
it was it must have been yeah it was
definitely before Co right 2018 I think
or 2019 something like that where I met
for time where you helped Connor film a
video or something like that where he
went to a date with a fan oh yeah my God
yeah I did do that yeah yeah yeah you
did yeah cuz a fan asked to have a date
it wasn't really a date it was just film
but yeah a fan asked to have a date and
I thought well [__] it let's see how it
goes then can I record it though yeah it
was it wasn't like a real day but it was
fun uh it was it was a funny video I
remember that yeah cuz we stayed at uh
my my previous editor's house and it was
it was it was rough what's what's your
favorite country you have visited then o
that's hard I would say maybe Amsterdam
cuz that's really nice like the whole
city is so walkable City but all right
no well yeah the entire place it's
pretty nice yeah what do you mean I
country [__] uh well I haven't walkable
no it is walkable but it's like when I
went from LA to Amsterdam that was such
a huge difference like we would walk for
like an hour on foot and it was like
nothing it was like oh that's so
nice you just just describe you just
describe walkable there's no homeless
people fighting are up there nobody
threatening with reason why La is not a
walkable City you know no even out of
Europe I I would say it's one of the
better ones maybe M like if you're not
in the very center cuz I've been to yeah
most of them like I I don't see what
what the hate about Paris is I like
Paris really really well I've lived in
Paris okay what the [__] when did you
live in Paris uh I worked there for like
two summers we doing what uh Disneyland
what oh yeah you did tell me this oh
yeah [__] Disneyland at Disneyland in
Paris and you ended up not hating the
city no I'm very surprised I lived in a
ghetto like outside on the outskirts of
Paris and Disneyland is like even
further out it's like Paris but it's
like hanada to Tokyo oh narar Nar so
like Disneyland is fun and uh Paris
itself cuz if you go as a tourist it's
can be cool also I knew how to speak
French so I went everywhere can you
still speak French uh I can like enough
oh wow but not perfectly okay so like I
I went to everywhere like trying to
speak French but if you start out in
English then you're not going to have a
good time yeah I think that's the big
difference you know just got to show
that you're not English that's the first
step if they get through that then
you're like I me I that's pretty why I I
didn't like it as much I'm like man
everyone [__] sucks here